You're in a lot of trouble you want to get out
of here right what if i can offer you a chance
what does my chance require someone's changing the
proper flow of time you're here to help me catch
this guy who is it someone very familiar you gotta
be kidding me he could be hiding anywhere anytime
how nice to meet you this was something
i could never have seen coming
it was really helpful to listen to tom talking
about the mischief because she's another version
of loki but it was important to make sure she
was unique because she's silvie she's not loki
what exactly makes a loki a loki
independence authority style awful fruit
loki comes face to face with sylvie and wants to
know more a few questions you're in my way the
audience will be intrigued by sylvie's arc and the
back story it really just sets the groundwork for
this character the universe wants to break free
so it manifests chaos like me sylvie is certainly
leaping into the mcu with extraordinary energy
people are gonna love it expect the unexpected
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
marvel loki episode 4 trailer video there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here and reveals about
sylvie's character so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i'm doing
videos for all the marvel disney plus series this
year there's a whole bunch more stuff coming up
with marvel what if later this summer i'll talk
about that as we get closer to the loki finale too
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment with your favorite easter egg
from the series so far careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on loki so far too if
you haven't seen the episodes but the new trailer
for episode 4 just gives us all the clues we
need to know how loki and silvie make it off
lamentous one despite the fact that the ark has
just been destroyed and the 10 pad portal device
seems like it's broken there were so many comments
on my episode 3 video about people just expecting
big twists for a lot of the big macguffins during
the episode like maybe loki is lying maybe it's
not really broken maybe silvie was enchanting
him the whole time maybe he stole the time stone
i think after Wandavision and after falcon and
winter soldier you have to be careful about how
many twists you tried to expect because that was
kind of the deal with wanda vision like maybe this
is going on maybe these other things are going on
in the actual plot of both of those series wound
up being way simpler than anybody ever expected
so occam's razor with loki i would expect like
one kind of twist but not like a twist within a
twist within a twist it's not going to be that
complicated remember there are only six episodes
so they have to blow through this plot really fast
but if you look at this scene here at the end of
the trailer the footage is out of order you see
sylvie sitting down again with loki for another
loki to loki chat amidst the apocalypse the planet
is still about to be destroyed that hasn't changed
but this scene here is the longer version of the
footage that we got in the earlier trailers i
tried to tell people that this wasn't vermeer
and she was not black widow but people just did
not want to believe it last year when we first
got those trailers i think at the time people
were still fresh off of avengers end game and
they were just looking for ways that marvel could
bring natasha back from the dead with big twists
but silvie says some really interesting things to
loki here she's speaking mostly in metaphors but
she says the universe wants to break free break
free of the time keepers the sacred timeline or
the concept of the sacred timeline so it manifests
chaos like me so just to be clear she's not trying
to say that she was created specifically by
eternity which is the living embodiment of
the multiverse for the express purpose of killing
the timekeepers and destroying the sacred timeline
she was born under normal circumstances in her own
alternate timeline born as a loki but then changed
her name to sylvie laufeydottir and the way
they're explaining her backstory especially during
episode 3 is that she was always supposed to have
been way more of an oddball outsider than even our
regular loki and her version of odin was a way
worse father because frigga died when she was
a child everyone break out your bad marvel dad's
tier list odin isn't the worst marvel dad but he
is up there so when you hear stories about loki
causing mischief as a child like the stories that
thor told during ragnarok imagine sylvie getting
into way more trouble rebelling against all forms
of authority as a child not just rebelling against
odin and asgard but also as we see from the other
trailer footage causing enough trouble to get
herself arrested by the tba as a child meaning she
would have had to have done something major enough
to create a nexus event so this is probably when
she became a variant maybe she got her hands on an
infinity stone as a child or she stole something
ultra powerful from odin's vault either way she
gets hauled in she becomes a variant and that's
basically where her story as a variant begins and
as we know now everyone who works at the tva is
supposed to be a variant and they just get their
minds wiped so they forget that they're variants
but during episode three silvie didn't know that
her magic would be nullified inside the tva so i
think that means that she never became an agent of
the tva like r loki or hunter c20 or any of these
other variants like mobius so that means that at
some point after this when she's a little girl she
would have had to escape custody somehow she said
that her mission to destroy the tva had been in
the works for a long long time so it sounds like
that started after she escaped the tva as a child
i wouldn't be surprised though if she chose the
name sylvie for herself after she became a variant
but as for them escaping lamentus one so after
they have that conversation you can clearly see
her being arrested again by the tva carted into
one of those time theaters sitting down for a
scene very similar to episode one when loki got
carted in and had to watch the highlight reel
of the marvel movies like loki's greatest hits
but this time make it sylvie's greatest hits
so that's probably when they do all the scenes
for her backstory so simple explainer for how
they escape the planet remember falcon winter
soldier wandavision theory very simple way to
explain this it's probably mobius in the tva just
catching up to them shortly after this moment
notice this footage of loki walking amidst all the
other tva hunters with sylvie in chains in one of
those collars to dampen her powers and then you
see this footage of loki staring at a portal also
on lamentis one like the portal is back to the
tva and he's just pausing for a second hesitating
before he walks back through so the tva probably
portals into lamentis one rescues them but also
formally arrests sylvie and the reason why loki is
hesitating to go back for just a hot second here
is probably because he's unsure of what's going to
happen next sylvie's kind of growing on him this
past episode and he's starting to understand her
message about the tva and the timekeepers being
bad and because of all the fight scenes with them
together back to back later in the trailer it
sounds like at some point in the next episode or
two he does help her he's also probably trying to
figure out how to break the secret to mobius that
he's actually a variant this also explains a big
easter egg or a big setup moment from episode two
so remember the scene where he's with renslayer
they're having the drinks and he creates another
ring on that table and renslayer yells at him she
says that he keeps doing that keeps creating rings
but mobius doesn't remember creating rings so the
idea is the tva probably wipes everyone's minds on
the regular and that's why he doesn't remember the
way that sylvie was talking about hunter c20 the
big intro scene where she goes into her memories
she said she had to go back a hundred years but
she was still able to find her original memories
when she was on earth so similar things probably
happen for all the other people working at the tva
they still have some of their original memories
that start to bubble up eventually and they have
to have their minds wiped again to reset them so
that they don't remember that they're variants
another cool detail about how the tva exists
outside of normal space time silvie says that
she had to go back a hundred years to get that
memory and when you're in that scene it looks like
present-day earth so that explains how that big
multiverse war that miss minutes was talking about
can still happen in the future technically because
the tva exists outside of normal space time so for
them it's in the past but for the regular avengers
characters after end game in present day it
happens in the future that being a big lead-in to
the idea of what's happening with doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness the collapse of all reality
and the eventual setup for an avengers secret wars
arc way later down the road there were also a lot
of people wondering whether or not renslayer knows
the secret about them wiping everyone's minds
everyone being variants because she's so high
up on the ladder it seems like in the tva you
assumed that a few people up there at the top
would know the true secret but so far the way they
portrayed her character the vibe that she gives
off she seems like a relatively good character
who's just blinded to what's really going on
like she's played the good soldier this whole
time following orders since she would have become
a variant and started working there later you see
footage of loki and sylvie fighting their way up
the elevator into this space where the timekeepers
are supposed to be like loki is fighting with her
short sword here so this point they're working
together taking out all these other people that
are supposedly protecting whatever is up here
whether or not it's the time keepers or something
else you clearly see sylvie throwing her short
sword at something like at the frame and it seems
like they have their version of a wizard of oz
reveal like who is really behind the curtain here
and based on her reaction her frustration here it
seems like as we would expect it's not what sylvie
or loki are expecting like they discover something
deeper about the lie renslayer also seems like she
chases them up here but it's unclear if she's
still fighting them or if she starts to question
things and eventually helps them my guess just
based on the way they're pacing the loki's series
out is that she probably won't start helping them
till the end of the series because i think that
they want her to come off as a relatively good
character the way gugu and badam raw talked about
it i think we'll get more of her backstory in the
later episodes but there's still a whole bunch
of other apocalypse scenes in these trailers
for different planets that we haven't seen yet
like there's this alternate version of loki
during the original avengers movie inside the
avengers tower there's president loki that we
haven't met yet i'm still kind of wondering if
the real kid loki we see is young male loki like
a more comic book accurate kid loki i guess you
could think of young sylvie as a version of kid
loki but kid loki in the comics is more of like
a teenage version of loki like a young avengers
age loki he's not like a tiny little kid i also
still really like the idea that miss minutes is
somehow connected to all the darker shady stuff
going on with the time keepers in general in the
tba it would be funny if she were the real main
villain like a rogue ai like ultron was there
was the funny moment with loki trying to swat
her at the beginning of episode 2 i think that
was kind of set up for something bigger later on
like we'll see another version of this scene later
in the series with them actually trying to chase
down a version of miss minutes it's always the
one you least suspect but my full loki episode 4
video we'll post next week just like normal i have
some new rick and morty season five that i'll be
posting next it may be a new shangxi video about
what happened to abomination after incredible hulk
in avengers endgame just to explain where he's
been this whole time if you have any special
requests or big questions that you want me to
do videos about let me know in the comments
congratulations alfredo sauce you're the giveaway
winner for my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here for my
brand new shengshi trailer video with abomination
versus wong and click here for my full loki
episode 3 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!